what up space fam goes in here from
anime up we're back at it again to
discuss the latest craziest chapter in
the one piece story and although we had
to wait a bit for this one
it was well worth it so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing these one piece videos on the
channel and want to keep them coming the
best thing you can do is smash that like
button and share this video with your
nakama if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos also
as you wait for future chapters to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i got videos about
the red scabbard supernovas yonko
and much much more link in the
description i've also been streaming on
the anime uproar twitch
pretty much daily so come hang out link
to that is in the description as well
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all the chapters called
remnants and we'll discuss its
significance more
when we actually get to that part in the
chapter i do want to mention
we got a very fun colored image of the
straw hat crew
and them smiling eating and having a
good time and for all those people
desiring to see
zorro cut kaido he is drinking from a
bowl
with what seems to be a blue kaiosk
dragon on it could it be nothing yes
but there has been talk of zorro
possibly using his impressive sword
skills on
kaido like the red scabbers have been
doing so i thought it was worth
mentioning
so far at least it does seem like swords
are the best way to harm kaido
so luffy might need some help in that
regard i was also
super hyped to see that we got the
official colors of yamato who has white
hair
and red horns and a white outfit as well
very cool stuff
and this is hype even though she doesn't
play a huge role in this
chapter we also see luffy with his coat
looking tough and stylish
and lastly for my fellow demon player
fans out there we do also see my boy and
goku on the cover probably advertising
the upcoming movie
that should have dropped on the 16th
right away we start with some really
interesting stuff big mom
has come across pero sparrow who had
teamed up with marco the phoenix to take
down kaido
pero sparrow never liked the idea of his
mother teaming up with arguably her
biggest rival for the pirate king
position
however big mom is like trust me dude i
know what i'm doing and in marco's case
he sees that the invitation to work
together between him and pero sparrow
seems to be no more i don't know how
perospero thought big mom would change
her mind because of him but we'll see if
perospero ends up doing some stuff to
make things more difficult for kaido
anyways
but even though now big mom and marco
are seemingly enemies
they aren't jumping to kill each other
there is a certain level of respect
between everyone present
and that's something i enjoy seeing big
mom does comment however that
whitebeard's remnants have lost their
way
pointing to the title of the chapter
remnant means a small remaining quantity
of something but it's pretty much what
remains of the whitebeard pirates
and marco answers back that they're not
bound to whitebeard's will
and remember that whitebeard wanted to
save luffy rather as marco says everyone
who's left is free and in marco's case
still choosing to help luffy and man i
just gotta say marco is so cool
i just had to mention that he's just
casually talking to big mom here and
making potentially groundbreaking
alliances
very cool stuff big mom looks
intimidating and says dead men give no
orders
so do as you will and this is an
interesting conversation because the
idea of wills
constantly comes up in one piece and the
idea of inheriting wills
it is true that dead men can't control
the actions of the living but people
like marco or the scabbards
still can freely decide to carry on
their wills which inevitably
ends up happening obviously even though
odin's dead
people are still very much carrying on
his will and you can even say his orders
in the present
carrot pops up seemingly seeing pero
sparrow and wanting to avenge pedro
i have no idea how carrot expects to
take on the big mom pirates but i am
intrigued to see how this develops
this scene does show though how
complicated war can be literally pero
sparrow can be an enemy one second
and he could have easily been an ally
the next if big mom was on board
i still feel like the marco and pero
sparrow alliance will have some
significance moving forward otherwise
there wasn't really a point in
introducing it in my opinion luffy's
time to shine in this chapter is him
just running to catch up with kaido
and him thanking people for clearing the
way this was very comedic to me to see
our protagonist passingly like this
but this chapter is not really his time
to shine yet so we just have this
comedic drive-by moment for now
reminding us to not worry since his time
is coming the island is in an uproar an
anime uproar
and we got maria giving us some music to
go along with the crazy events
she speaks of two who wish to be united
but could never be together
at last they will meet beneath the light
of the moon
while passions run high we definitely
have passions running high on this
moonlit night and this song is framed as
romantic but it can also be seen as
reflecting the current happenings in
mono we also see yamato as maria plays
and although we saw her foreground in
the cover this is pretty much all we get
from her now
she's still chasing shinobu and
momonosuke and in a way now
odin and momonosuke are meeting the
father and son obviously couldn't
otherwise meet because odin's dead but
since yamato
keeps insisting on being odin that
impossible meeting is sort of happening
just like in maria's song
am i stretching a bit yes probably but i
do think it's interesting that those
lines were sung
right as we were being shown momonosuke
yamato as maria continues to rock
out in what is sure to be a glorious
scene in the anime we jump to the battle
between the red scabbars and kaido
absolutely gorgeous art here odin told
kaido
not to underestimate his samurai and i
think we all did to an extent
but these guys have more than delivered
on what was expected of them and they
continue to do so
as i've been mentioning frequently kaido
is not
undefeatable as soon as he was
introduced we were told that he tasted
defeat as a pirate multiple times
it's just that no one could kill him not
even himself
we were also told always been on kaido
in a one-on-one fight but this clearly
isn't a one-on-one fight
we got nine underestimated samurai here
counting ezo
and they're doing absolutely amazing and
keep in mind
help is coming in the form of luffy and
friends too kaido is mythical in every
sense when he
roars lightning comes out although the
scabbards succeed in avoiding any damage
we get sulong nekomamushi hit kaido with
his paw
kawamatsu slices kaido's mouth and beast
pirates continue to be shocked that
these nine are actually hurting kaido
just as kaido sends kawamatsu flying
inwarashi stabs him with his sword leg
penetrating his skin keep in mind when
people tried the guillotine kaido the
blade just cracked so the fact that
these guys are penetrating his skin is
no small feat
izo and kiku attack and hit but kaido
says enough nonsense
none of the attacks bear any resemblance
to odin and let's keep in mind that odin
in my view was best in kaido in their
past fight before odin was distracted
into thinking that his son was in danger
odin arguably had kaido on the ropes
before the distraction
and kaido did not end up giving him a
fair fight after he used a distraction
to take him out
these nine here are odin students and
they have trained and improved since
then
so it's not crazy to think that together
if they internalize their teachers
lessons
they could hurt kaido especially if we
throw in kaido's mental instability
right now
just like how the memory of yorichi
freaks out muzon and awakens old wounds
and demon slayer
i feel like odin's memory is
destabilizing kaido
leading to weaker defenses as well
although we must also assume that kairo
is much stronger than he was back then
during the odin fight
this is when we get my favorite moment
in this chapter ryzo who i must admit
that i underestimated
comes in clutch showing he's the mvp of
this chapter
rhizo uses a ninja scroll to seal
kaido's blast breath attack
and then proceeds to unleash it back
against him what an amazing moment
even kaido must be hurt by his own
powerful attack i absolutely love it
that rhizo got his chance to shine here
and again we have beast pirates shocked
that kaido is taking so much damage
and clearly kaido is having trouble or
he would have just finished them all off
by now
we have a flashback of odin wanting to
teach his two-sword style to his
students
but at the time they didn't want to
learn however by now it seems like
inuarashi kinemon denjiro and
ashra actually have learned it which is
hype because that style was clearly the
most
effective we've ever seen against kaido
kaido calls it a cheap imitation
and we get more flashbacks of odin
talking about ryo
akidowano term for busochoku haki
this type of hockey when advanced enough
can be emitted
from the user or their weapons and
destroy the target from inside out
luffy thought that this might help him
hurt the seemingly invincible kaido
and clearly it does work on kaido the
four mentioned red scabbards use the
exact move
paradise totsuka that odin used to harm
kaido
so bad so many years ago not only that
they use it on the scar odin left
reopening it amazing stuff simply
amazing they are building on odin's
legacy together so whatever they
accomplish
it's thanks to odin as well i still
can't really see the red scabbards
beating kaido on their own
but man they have been instrumental in
hurting him and if we keep getting
people in the house like luffy to keep
giving damage to kaido's reopened odin
wound
then victory actually seems possible at
this point
and how will big mom react to this will
she defend
a weakened kaido or see this as an
opportunity to betray him as perospero
would like her to do
crazy stuff again i don't want to over
correct and say that the red scabbers
will be able to take down kaido alone
but 100 percent they've done more damage
than i expected
and they were way more epic than i
expected them to be in this fight
especially rhizo
my personal mvp of this chapter odin's
spirit
clearly lives on and is haunting kaido
big time with luffy being able to emit
hockey
and cause even more internal damage to
kaido's worst ever
and reopened wound i feel like we can
finally begin to see kaido's defeat in
our minds
although we've still got a long way to
go to get there no doubt despite how
this last panel makes it look
and that is it for this chapter let me
know how you like this chapter and what
you expect to see next
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming the best you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with your nakama
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one piece videos
also as you wait for future chapters to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist where i got videos
about the red scabbard supernovas yonko
and much
much more link in the description i've
also been streaming on anime uproar
twitch pretty much daily so come hang
out link to that is in the description
as well
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you